about the Muslim portrayal of Jesus I
believe I spoke to you briefly I don't
know if you remember but um we was
talking about Jesus in Islam and how you
guys say that Jesus is a is a Muslim and
so yeah so the I I just don't understand
how Jesus can be a Muslim is it yeah we
good good to go so I I don't understand
how Jesus can be a Muslim obviously when
Islam came with Muhammad so if you guys
can reconcile that historically and
logically I'd like to get into that good
meaning of Islam means submission okay
Islam means submission all right anyone
there are too many now of them
now okay
huh you want me as well to record for
you okay subscription
ended yeah
yeah okay all right so the Islam means
submission anyone who submit his will to
the will of God is a Muslim okay yes so
for example when Jesus said for example
if we wanted to use the Bible even
though it's not a source of information
for us but Jesus said let it be not my
will but yours who yeah Jesus said to to
the father father let it be not my will
but yours so from this this is a total
submission to the will of the father am
I right and that's why if that true
story that story is true that mean
that's one of the things that shows
anyone submit his will willingly to the
will of God is a Muslim so that's the
meaning of ISL Islam wasn't introduced
by Muhammad Islam is the faith of God
which God has revealed since the since
Abraham and Noah and all of I got you I
got you so so if we're like going to why
you say it means I understand you it
means I understand
you so so with what I'm understanding I
agre okay yeah so so just
just so so just to simplify it you're
saying Muslim Muslim means yeah finished
that question yeah let me let me back
you know back are you here to debate I
thought you to ask question well I'm I'm
here for a discussion would you like a
discussion I thought you came here I
came I came with a discussion yeah I
came for I came for a discussion I hope
I hope you're not
a we good for a discussion y'all is that
this speaker corner right okay speak
speaker Corner speak corner it doesn't
mean I have to discuss with you one
second that's fine I don't I don't have
to you're right understand you're right
but you was having a spirited
conversation with the brother before I'm
here with an honest discussion have it
why are we wasting time go let's go
let's go okay let's go all right so when
you said yeah yeah okay so when you said
keep coming you ready okay cool so you
said being a Muslim is means one who
submits their will to God right so now
I'm going ask you this question is Allah
a father in any sense is Allah the
father in any sense yes now the issue is
the misinterpretation of the Old
Testament it's is a father in any sense
my friend the misin reputation for the
New Testament addressing God the creator
of Jesus the creator of the heavens is
he a
father that's all I want to know I'm yes
he doesn't have to answer either either
either you answer you take my answer as
it is it's not an answer though that's
up to you I'm do you think do you think
I have to please you in my answer well
no I was hoping that you I was hoping
you could give an honest answer instead
of waffling around I'm saying to you I'm
saying Speak let's see let's see
you remember the question you remember
the question the father is the father is
Allah the father now that's the question
let's see you're right he doesn't need
to let's see if he does though cuz he
promised he will let's see if he does go
ahead my go go ahead okay for us to
understand what is the context we need
to have the original context textt bring
me the original context and then when we
when we read is the answer when we read
ital language then we will understand
what exactly Jesus said
so now now now here for us I said to you
earlier what was the question if the
story what was the question no cuz you
told me to listen what was the question
you're not listening no what was the
question brother
brother yeah is Allah the father did we
get an answer today yet can you let him
you told me he was answering all right
so you told we all we all waitting for
the answer okay is Allah a father in any
sense you're the one who said you're
going to be silent if you're not going
to be Sil I didn't say I was going to be
silent I said I was going to wait for
the answer you should if you want to let
him give the answer you should let him
we'll see if you told me he was going to
answer so I'm going to see if you can be
unbiased to see if he answers or not
you'll be honest right I'm I'm going
trust you I'm going trust you I'm notlim
I'm all right I'm going trust you so is
Allah a father yeah you got let
him listen thank you we got a not back
there if you have if you interrupt me
again we'll end the discussion that's
fine I hope you don't waffle get to the
answer that's my it's my chance you ask
you ask I just like to keep you focused
that's all no no no don't if you
interrupt me again I would finish the
the the discussion that's okay you
understand that's that's fine with me it
means if we don't get an answer from it
it's supposed to be a sh go in peace
then go in peace so no
answer no answer guys so so notice here
I just wanted to put this on on display
here notice here when we had a a a
simple question how is Jesus a Muslim
what he did was is he went to the Bible
he went to the Bible where Jesus says
father let your will be done not my will
he said this shows he's a Muslim so I
said okay is Allah a father I can't get
an answer right now because he know
because he knows once he answers this
he's cooked so please give just give us
an honest answer man we're waiting I
told
you we done go in peace you're not
waiting you're not waiting let's go
let's go go in peace let's go go in
peace go in peace you're scared of the
way that he's going to answer that
question I think I think he's scared of
the answer I think he's scared of the
answer SC he's scared of he's scared of
Discord he's scared of Discord you w't
scared you're right you're right and I
think that if he wasn't scared he'd
answer the
question and and if you wasn't and if
you wasn't scared hey brother if you
wasn't scared you would have told him
hey brother you're not answering the
question so everybody here can see he
didn't answer the question everybody
here except for the people that's behind
there can see he didn't answer the
question because this is what it is I'm
I'm going go in peace I'm going go in
peace I'm going go in peace but this is
what it is this is what it is if if
Jesus says that let the father's will be
done and that means he's a Muslim that
means that Jesus is a blasphemer
committing shk saying that Allah is his
father which you know you can't say so
is either Jesus is a false prophet and a
blasphemer or he's the true Son of God
and not a
Muslim thank you there it is
guys let's see who's next